good afternoon thank you all for joining
us for this exciting event i'm glad to
finally have an audience at white ui and
you also have some people joining us
online and we cannot wait to welcome
excellent visitor on campus very soon
my name is florian carl i'm the manager
of the yale quantum institute and the
curator of this series of non-technical
talks co-sponsored by their friends at
the frankie program for science and the
humanity
the goal of this event is to combat
science phobia and to bring a new regard
to quantum physics and science in
general
by having experts cast new lights on
oven
on often overlooked aspects of the
scientific work
this series starting in the spring
semester of 2017 and we discussed a
variety of topics among them the
interaction of music and quantum physics
art and science physics and dance
board games and space exploration
mathematics and crochet and so on and so
on
for this evening we have the pleasure to
welcome the multimedia artist composer
and writer paul miller also known as dj
spooky
his work immerse audiences in a blend of
genres global culture environmental
social issues and paul miller has
collaborated with an array of recording
artists including metallica
chuck d steve rage and okono but also
with renowned physicists like brian
greeney
marcelo glyser stephan alexander and
general events
his large-scale multilight performance
pieces including rebirth of a nation
terranova
that was commissioned by the brooklyn
academy of music and the sole
counterpoint
that he wrote during his 2014 residency
at the seoul institute of the arts
and his big multimedia project quantopia
the evolution of the internet that he
will talk a little bit later on during
this talk was commissioned by san
francisco archive the internet arcade in
2019 we welcome paul miller in september
as our third artist in residence at the
yale quantum institute
in this role uh paul miller will
interact with our faculty members
researchers and students at our events
and color health and produce data-driven
multimedia immersive artwork which is
based on the work of researcher quake ui
and their collaboration
if you're interested in meeting paul
miller with him and work with him please
reach out to me and i'll arrange a
meeting for you
tonight's full represent an informal
history of invisible things the talk
will last about 45 minutes to 50 minutes
and then we have time for questions and
if you are online please use the q a
feature to ask your question
please help me welcome paul miller thank
you um first and foremost i just want to
say um
thanks so much to everyone for joining
me and i know it's a gorgeous weather
outside so
um it's a real treat to be with human
beings and you forget that the pandemic
it's been a very long 18 months right i
mean well
people in a room
who would guess
um so what i want to do today is unpack
a couple of issues that will give you
guys a little bit of a foundation to
some of the work i'll be uh looking at
over the next several months but also
give you a bit of context to why
um the relationship between yale quantum
institute and me as an artist
relates to kind of the legacy of what i
think of as interdisciplinary approach
to the sciences and the arts and above
all creating a more robust conversation
between science and art and of course
the role of the composer and artist in
the 21st century
so
i have a tendency to be very non-linear
so i'm not going to give you guys a
normal straight ahead uh powerpoint so
that's just the way it is
all right we begin with a simple image i
wanted to kind of begin with this idea
of pattern recognition in nature
this is broccoli and amusingly enough if
you start to think about nature
biomimicry and mathematics there's
always a relationship between how we
look at pattern recognition and how
pattern recognition actually
informs almost all aspects of human
cognition and how we put together the
fragments of meaning that make up our
for like what we're just going to make
up upon here our cognitive bandwidth
and how much we process the information
around us
is based on one could argue whether
you're david hume or for that matter
rousseau or fast forward to other
philosophers like delusion matali or
jacques derrida you name it the whole
pun here is that pattern recognition is
how human beings navigate the very
complex world around us and how it gives
us grounding in a world that one could
argue
is filled with uncertainties even about
the basic humanity and the way that we
relate to this complex universe around
us so if we jump from broccoli to
fractals this is mandelbrot set
you can easily see that there's a kind
of a compelling relationship between
mathematics and nature and above all um
nature as the human uh evolves over the
last several hundred thousand years uh
we can easily see that we've been in
this process of trying to um there's a
very wonderful israeli philosopher yuval
harari if you haven't read sapiens it's
a great book
human beings have been involved with
this notion of sort of suppressing
aspects of nature as we move further
into the 21st century and the industrial
revolution gave way to one could argue
an information revolution and now as we
move further into a data-driven society
we'll be seeing far more engagements
with disruption of nature and of course
that's where
environmentalists uh call now the
anthropocene era so math nature and
above all pattern recognition these are
things that are compelling but also
deeply disturbed the
the psychologist sigmund freud would
call this the uncanny uh the unheimlick
it's a german term for meaning unhomely
or at the edge of the familiar so
for many in the audience this is a
simple kind of graph diagram of a
mathematical process but if you bounce
it off of nature and you see the same
thing and how
this vegetable for example is just
optimizing its relationship to sunlight
to be able to optimize its relationship
to resources and above all crete one
could argue a tasty meal you know it
means that nature and humans we are not
separate and above all the 19th century
one could argue took us down a strange
path of industrialization and the idea
of scarcity and above all this notion
that capitalism had set up this kind of
um
this notion of a deterministic universe
which leads me to this gentleman
this is uh simone pierre
um he's a gentleman who felt that at the
beginning of the maybe the middle of the
18th century at the beginning maybe the
late 18th century um there was above all
a relationship to revolution
one could argue the french and the
americans and
many of the other kinds of uh global
cultures were involved with a series of
upheavals that many environmentalists
have traced to what they call sort of
the short um ice age there was a
tremendous amount of crop failure in the
mid 18th century because uh a volcanic
eruption had sent a tremendous amount of
particles into the atmosphere
and so winters were colder and longer
and summers were kind of faint and so
there's a lot of people who feel that
the 18th century upheavals including the
revolutions can be tied directly to
climate change
but he wrote an essay that's going to
inform some of the discussion today that
the english translation is just simply
called a philosophical essay on
probabilities
and he felt that you could actually if
you had enough computational power that
you would be able to predict the
movement of every particle making up the
entire universe now here in the 21st
century our notion of computational
realism of being able to actually have
the computational power to be able to
engage this kind of thinking um it's a
pretty powerful moment and you one can
argue that the 18th century
deterministic model whether it's
newtonian classical physics or whether
you know later on one could argue that
this kind of deterministic thinking set
the tone for the 20th century's idea of
the industrial psychology that led to
all other elements being disrupted
when i say all other elements for
example
humans and nature the idea of the human
place as we move further into the
anthropocene and above all the idea that
patterns were rigidly controlled and
deterministic
the idea of free will for example and
facebook free will on facebook and
obviously there's a huge scandal right
now
but if you look at cambridge analytica
and many of the other
uh
data
mining and data surveillance industries
they're based on this idea that it's
relatively trivial to compute how human
beings engage with the information
around them and the patterns around them
and thus
things like instagram facebook tick tock
these are all
computational machineries that are
engaged with manipulation and above all
sort of colonizing the subconscious as
it moves further into a data-driven uh
narrative so
pierre simon de place i'll just read
this aloud just so everyone can kind of
be on the same page here he says we may
regard the present state of the universe
as the effect of its past and the cause
of its future an intellect which at a
certain moment would know all forces
that set nature in motion and all
positions of all items of which nature
is composed
if this intellect were also vast enough
to submit these data to analysis it
would embrace in a single formula the
movements of the greatest bodies of the
universe and those of the tiniest atom
for such an intellect nothing would be
uncertain and the future just like the
past will be present before its eyes
now
whether you're an aristotelian or
someone who believes in the sort of
platonic ideals of you know the
foundations of western philosophy this
still relates to how we think about
structure and its relationship to how a
determinist versus indeterminate sort of
cognitive process works now other
philosophers like rousseau for example
would call this you sort of the the
unmoved mover a daemon a demon
d-a-e-m-o-n
uh that would immediately create a
structure where you'd have to always be
guessing but guess what
um you know you can fast-forward to
schrodinger and other kinds of
physicists who are still influenced by
this and schroniger's infamous cat you
know where you're able to think about uh
the idea of randomness and chance
operations
all this still lingers over the
conversation
so from these 18th century philosophers
rousseau le place and so on you can
easily see that there was kind of a
deep tension in philosophy and science
and of course newton navigated that and
led the path for people like einstein
so
let's give you guys a little bit of
context i'm an artist a writer a
musician who's deeply enmeshed in
thinking about the conversation between
science and the arts
my father was dean of howard
university's law school
i grew up in washington dc in the
ancient 1970s i'll just show you guys
quick uh this is dupont circle in
washington dc in the early 70s
my mother was a historian of design and
my father was dean of power university's
law school
so there was a tremendous amount of
political activity at that time you had
jag or uber you had nixon the vietnam
war is raging um so some of the cases my
father represented for example
he was a lawyer for
angela davis and the black panthers very
political
so our household was near dupont circle
i don't know if anybody here knows dc
but growing up in that region there was
you know you had the embassies you had a
very international cosmopolitan scene i
had friends from china russia india
japan
so growing up in a downtown washington
dc context we also had there was a
vegetarian punk scene for example i
don't know if you guys know bands like
fugazi which was a minor threat or bad
brains
anyone who's into brash punk i don't
know if these um you know you guys might
not be into that but it was popular at
the time
so growing up uh in a cosmopolitan
situation made me realize that the idea
that science the arts and history were
all kind of in this american
uneasiness and as we've seen during the
pandemic we're not just facing a
biological pandemic we're facing an
ideological and political crisis based
on the crisis of democracy as it
collides with the social media and
facebook and twitter and instagram and
so on so
going back to that time period um the
legacies i'm inherited are from that
kind of era a critique of the political
discourse uh thinking about human rights
thinking about history and this kind of
disruptive innovation that was going on
as the world became more and more
digital
so fast forward to uh our current moment
this is some of my artwork uh this is a
fun remix of louis carroll um i tend to
always incorporate uh found materials
this is some of my visual artwork um i'm
a big fan of lewis carroll and obviously
he was someone who would play with the
mythology of mathematics and many of his
works of course alice in wonderland are
foundational too one could argue this
sort of computational narratives that we
inhabit now um
in fact the science fiction writer neil
stephenson if you haven't read his work
uh he's a wonderful writer uh his book
snow crash for example he coined the
term the metaverse uh which if you
haven't encountered it's it's it's well
worth exploring
so when you start to think about the
visual arts um many of my other friends
in this kind of context are artists such
as chef ferry who um shep for example uh
made the obama hope poster
uh which became very popular
in uh when obama was running there's
also you know kind of all sorts of other
artists who i think you know he did chev
just obey he went to uh uh risd and i
went to bowdoin college up in may so
just giving you guys a little bit of
context if you haven't seen his work
you've probably seen the stickers that
say andre the gemini has a posse uh i
mean we've known each other since we're
in college um you know i went to bowdoin
and uh risdy had better parties so when
we drive down to visit on the weekends
all right so you have a little bit of
context and now how does this relate to
science let's give you guys a little bit
of a kind of an interpretation there's a
very dear friend of mine named margaret
atwood if you haven't read her work um
currently she the world is feeling like
one of her books actually the
handmaidens tale
um margaret
is a science fiction writer who uses
feminist narratives to critique how we
think about the near future and control
of women's bodies
the handmaid's tale is a
absolute classic hands down if you
haven't read it but she inspires a lot
of my thinking right now about the
legacy of the body and that's how it
orientates in this world of
how should i put this
coercive technologies
um now
some of my other work is presented uh in
the context of
installations at museums galleries
things like that uh one of my favorite
concerts and again i'm just using this
as an example
was we got the greek government to give
me the acropolis for an evening and i
projected um
throughout the ruins of the acropolis a
very infamous film uh by dw griffith
called birth of a nation
and for those who are into film history
the film is deeply controversial but
it's considered the dna of hollywood um
basically it's a film that shows it's a
kkk propaganda film
so um just for the record just to clear
clarify uh just to tell you guys as an
audience i can assure you i'm not a kkk
member no
um but basically when i was in
negotiations with the greek government
they were like but why do you want to
play a kkk film at the acropolis
and i was like that's a you know good
question um so i was like look you guys
are greek you have comedy tragedy and
they're like oh i get it okay
so what they did was they allowed me to
put a sound system throughout the ruins
and what we ended up doing was
projecting different versions of the
film throughout the ruins so the
audience would come into this is called
the hair at atticus theater it's the
beginning of modern theater if you think
about this kind of semi-circle you can
still see that as a logo for our modern
movie theaters for example
now you might be thinking what does this
have to do with science i'm building up
to that but when you start to think
about uh these kind of temple of reason
athena um and pericles and the idea that
at that time democracy was very fragile
and the sort of the competition between
sparta and athens had generated this
intense
you know for lack of it or a critique of
the individual and the state um so the
later on the romans came in and
obviously they took over but this
theater became the kind of basic premise
of how rhetoric and how exchange of
ideas if you look on further of course
people like aristotle plato they would
be hanging out in this area and there
was an area called the agora the public
space
so somebody would jump up on a stone and
say you know this is my philosophy and
then somebody else
down the road would be saying hey this
is my philosophy and so on and so on so
what lingers over the conversation today
is pythagoras i'm a huge fan of him he
was also a controversial figure
and for those who are into the history
of mathematics he's generally considered
to be one of the first uh ancient
philosophers to be able to combine
tuning systems and math so the thing
about greeks cultures that they didn't
have zero and zero obviously is
incredibly important in the evolution of
how we think about the arts how we think
about tuning systems and how we think
about our modern binary code that drives
every digital device around you zeros
and ones
now pythagoras was
a deeply troubled person one could argue
he had a cult of mathematic
mathematicians around him you were not
allowed to see his face he would speak
through a veil
and he would only speak to you in
equations uh if you didn't if you were
not able to answer the equations you
were not worth speaking to
so he would um his most feared thing was
the square root of negative one as a
matter of fact there's rumors that he
would have you assassinated if you spoke
the square root of negative one aloud
because he felt that it would unravel
the universe
but what inspired pythagoras as an
ancient greek philosopher was this
tension between the public space and
math and if you look at the i'll give
you another example the oracle of delphi
for example all this goes to the heart
of western mathematics as tied into the
social process nothing was separate as
one could argue that interdisciplinary
foundation of western math inspired
architecture inspired philosophy
inspired pretty much everything that
currently drives our society so i'm
giving you a little bit of context on
this as a way of showing how art can
intervene in architecture art can also
intervene in the social process and
above all how we think about
contemporary practice as an
interdisciplinary space
um now
there's plenty of other art projects um
but i want to kind of give you guys a
little bit of context as well just for
that arc
so this is a very famous situation from
1915. uh it's the italian futurist uh
the gentleman on the left with the
mustache his name is luigi russolo
and basically at this time uh he came up
with this
series of projects called futurism and
basically uh the futurist movement
wanted to do invisible portraits of
the accelerated landscape
and he felt that the science of the
imagination literally recalled the
silent science of the imagination was
going to be about the tension of how a
culture was accelerating because of
industrialization
and he would have these futurist
concerts
now in 1915 the audience would walk into
a room much like this
and the concert would be coming out of
these crazy speakers
and so um the audience would riot people
would throw bottles at him they were
booing
and they would say you know where's the
band you know people uh were very upset
that the music was coming out of these
speakers and so as he he's like the
music of the future will all be coming
out of this and if you can look above
you and see all the little speakers you
can see who won
so from 1915 to our time period you can
usually see that the arts have had a
non-linear relationship both with the
industrial process with how people think
of the creative economy and above all
how science informs the practice of this
notion of sort of collapsing the silos
between mediums
now
another project that i just want to
bring to your attention
i went to antarctica for six weeks a
little while ago and there was a group
of scientists working on a project
called icecube it's antarctica has some
of the best
landscapes in the world for studying the
interaction of neutrinos
and what was beautiful about this
project was i got a chance to really go
deep into these larger landscapes of ice
and so when i was there i was doing what
i call acoustic portraits of ice
and ice is one of stunningly beautiful
material it's quite i'll show you in a
moment it's quite mathematical
but you can easily see this is a
landscape of devastation
the landscape is collapsing and you can
easily see in the collapse that's
creating the entire side of a mountain
for example now most of north america
was carved by the retreat of the
glaciers in the last several thousand
years and one could argue that we're in
an accelerated again anthropocene era
where nature and disruption of obviously
this summer was the wildest summer in
human history you know as far as fires
crazy weather patterns so buckle up it's
going to get a lot deeper
and going to antarctica from the heart
of new york and then doing what i call
these acoustic portraits was a real
eye-opener about the legacy of deep time
what you're seeing here is tens of
millions of years vanishing in the space
of a couple of decades
and so we're looking at a collision of
human time and deep time and so as a
composer how do you engage that how do
you think about this notion of pattern
recognition lingering over an entire
rise of a species our species in such a
short amount of time
so we're seeing the acceleration and
disruption of the entire biome and above
all we're also seeing that the human
sense of agency has now created you know
a way of thinking about our imagination
as applied to the entire universe around
us and you know one could argue
so maybe they weren't so far off maybe
we are imagining it all and our
intervention in this
is quite intriguing
so um
most of my books are published with mit
press
and i've been working with mit for many
years
the current book that i'm working on now
is called digital fictions so i just
want to show you this really quickly
this is a map it's a little blurry for
me i'll just zoom in really quickly it's
called the acoustic wave spectrum and i
use this in my last book because i
wanted to show people macro versus micro
level waveforms so imagine a waveform
that can i'll just zoom in so hopefully
you can see this
a waveform that would last over a
million years um so you're looking at
oceanic cycles you're looking at
tectonic plate movement you're looking
at i'll just zoom out here biospheric
cycles
and then maybe go we'll go down in the
scale to from millions of years to maybe
a pattern that might last over several
months global waves seasonal cycles
um you know and so on
planetary cycles rotation you know
different uh
phenomena and atmosphere then we zoom
down to the frequency in cycles to the
human range uh which is usually our
hearing is between one and one hundred
thousand you know cycles per second uh
we hear and can interact with you know
these kind of waveforms uh mechanical
oscillations surface waves uh what they
call cavitation uh conical waves uh
sound waves that obviously you know
going by or whatever
um and then if we go below
the human range down to a microacoustic
level you know millions of cycles per
second uh hundreds of thousands of
cycles per second
you can easily start to see that it
starts getting into the realm of quantum
mechanics and other forms of you know
thinking about these micro micro micro
micro levels um and the waveforms then
become far more what you call electro
acoustic magnetoacoustic
photonic and so on
and so the human ear obviously is not
evolved to engage this mechanism but
technology given our current uh process
we we've been able to engage these kinds
of waveforms and being able to then use
them for all sorts of different
approaches every device you have in your
pocket your cell phone
uh you know lights and all of this comes
out of the engagement between uh
obviously you know the last centuries
notions of quantum mechanics and then
updated through the filter of what
became a consumer culture based on that
so um you know these waveforms are all
part of everyday life but at the same
time there's a deep physics approach to
how the human ear helps us navigate the
world around us
so
each of those is different kinds of
processes and i want to make sure that
as an audience you realize that this is
information that can lead you down many
paths and i celebrate that
there's one of my favorite composers
also the greek composer his name is jana
sidnakis and he began a kind of approach
where he incorporated algorithms and he
called his style of composition still
cast the stochastic method
now here we are the yale quantum
institute in stochastic processes
obviously entropy and other kinds of
things those are again part of this
notion of quantum engagement and how do
we think about that but he would take
ancient greek mathematic formulas and
turn them into symphonies me and him did
a series of collaborations um and this
is the beginning of my career i had
obviously a lot more hair effective um
but the fun part about the way the
ancient greeks would think about math in
the everyday was that it was part of
this emotional engagement with how you
thought about intervening in pattern
recognition
so he's one of my favorite composers and
his work influences my thinking a lot
again he's one of the first composers to
use algorithms to generate symphonies um
now let's go to a little bit more
current stuff one project i'm working on
now is what you call computational
neuroscience and what i've been doing is
working on brain wave patterns uh the
human mind generates generally five
waveform frequencies that are easy to
quantify and measure delta theta alpha
beta gamma so obviously um each of those
is a frequency waveform that the human
ear doesn't pick up but your brain is
generating this and so
um what i've been doing uh over the
summer is working on sort of
mapping out brainwave patterns and then
using those to generate sound and then
being able to kind of balance meditation
or other approaches to thinking about
the brain and wave forms uh this is a
rough draft and this is just an acoustic
portrait of me thinking about some hip
hop
you know so at the moment this is a
rough draft it'll get more intense
probably 20 22. um but i'm giving you
guys little projects that can hopefully
give you a bit of context about why i'm
here with the yale quantum institute all
right
so that's one project
and then i did want to make sure that
you guys can also think about a little
bit of the history of what inspires my
work this is a very famous i collect
vinyl this is a very famous
collaboration between two of my favorite
composers sunra and john cage
john cage uh most famously created he's
called four minutes and 30 seconds uh or
is it four minutes 33 seconds i mean you
know
it's a famous piece about silence
basically and sunra is a legendary
figure who opened up the idea of noise
and free jazz
um the reason i think of these two and
physics is both of them were inspired by
interstellar phenomena and the idea of
silence now this is a very rare record
i've been collecting vinyl since i was a
kid and for me at least half of this
stuff is always about the notion of the
archive like how you engage your archive
how you reactivate your archive and then
how that becomes a collage process
so um these are all just bits and pieces
and by the way i could easily put this
in a slide format but i'm sick of
powerpoint
so i like the idea of kind of a
non-linear scroll here um so over the
last couple of months i've been really
i've been finishing a series of books
and some of my favorite authors this is
a gentleman by the name of william
gibson uh if you're not familiar with
his work he coined the term cyberspace
for example and his most famous book is
called neuromancer um so i i'm very
intrigued by the science fictional
relationship right now of moving further
into a data-driven society and there's
uh say for example there's a chinese
author who's a big influence on my work
right now
uh he wrote this book the three body
problems or the dark forest trilogy
um gibson uh in the idea of cyberspace
uh again neil stephenson is another
science fiction writer who influences my
thinking with his term the metaverse
all of which means that the science
fictional relationship to the world
around us um other authors like isaac
asimov or philip k dick also kind of
inform and inspire some of my work
um so
let's see i want to make sure that you
guys are getting a little bit of a broad
spectrum
i've been also doing some volunteer work
uh with reef restorations
because i'm fascinated with how ocean
currents
and
heat and temperature differentials can
actually generate this idea again of
living through pattern recognition but
also thinking about if the anthropocene
and radical disruption of how nature is
being wiped out by human
you know just human right patient or
basically um so i do scuba diving and
this is just uh kind of a series of fun
initiatives where we're kind of um
dealing with uh putting reefs back
together with uh there's an island
called bonaire that i go to occasionally
i also go to vanuatu solomon islands uh
tahiti fiji
and what we do is look at different reef
destruction and then try and reboot them
with either
grafts where you can actually have
different reefs from different regions
of the world and help them heal um
it's fun it's interesting but you can
easily see there's a mathematical
relationship going on here
and the way that the
the coral reefs are trying to optimize
their relationship to the ocean currents
and the salinity the temperature
differentials the sunlight
regretfully the planet is on fire right
now and the climate crisis is
you know it's
that's a whole different topic but i'm
heavily involved with a lot of climate
active
justice issues um
this is one of my favorite projects at
the moment and actually we're going to
be hopefully going back there or i will
be going back later this year to do a
series of sculptural projects and
looking at how to sculpt the coral so
that it can both be visually compelling
but also help it grow in a more robust
way
and again these are different radically
different projects i'm showing you guys
and i'm giving you guys the cliff notes
version just because of time
um
okay let's see really quick
um
i'm trying as much as possible to give
you guys a sensibility both how i do
research but also how that research then
informs my process
this is a gentleman who's also a big
inspiration to me since
and if you don't know his work he was in
the 8th and 9th century in baghdad at
the house of wisdom and he coined the
term algorithm which most westerners do
not know it's a it's an arabic term and
the arabs had borrowed uh these numbers
including zero from the hindu and their
notion of sanskrit mathematics um so his
term
basically
uh became the foundation of western math
because of fibonacci
and um musa alkazami generally is
considered to be
the other derivative of his name is
algebra
so one could argue um that the kind of
conversation between east west between
uh islam and science and the way muslim
culture actually helped preserve a lot
of records that the ancient greeks and
romans had they had taken one path in
mathematics but had not had zero for
example
which leads me to
a conversation that inspires pretty much
this entire residency and i want to make
sure to to foreground this
um
so
2019
was the 50th anniversary of the internet
and i was commissioned to do a symphony
celebrating this 50th anniversary so
from 1969 to 2019
the internet basically reached out and
changed the way we think about pretty
much everything this is the internet in
1969 there was four hubs
the first two hubs went live in october
1969 and again you guys are
uh based in physics so we can easily see
a exponential notion of growth so from
october to december you get the first
two helps were between ucla and stanford
research institute you can see those two
and then by december you have four then
keep going keep going keep going
next thing you know you have billions
and billions and billions of nodes but
um if you were a composer looking at
that notion of exponential growth how
would you turn that into a composition
so
um i was commissioned by the internet
archive which is a very
uh incredible organization out of san
francisco ucla and the san francisco
young women's choir so i reached out to
the gentleman who wrote this equation
um i just want to make sure you're aware
of this generally this is the equation
that set up what you call packet
switching which allows the entire
internet to work and the idea was the us
military through arpanet needed a
network to be able to send messages in
case there was a nuclear war or if there
was other disruption of major
communication systems so he figured out
a clever way to break a message into
component elements based on zeros and
ones
and essentially what i ended up doing
was working with him dr leonard kleinrop
if you look him up he's generally
considered to be one of the founders of
the internet
ended up working with him to
kind of do a research into how we think
about
message component systems
and i then took that and made it become
yeah so this is me and dr leonard
kleinrock
um and i took his equations and then had
a chorus uh the san francisco young
women's choir sing it and i'll just show
you what that would look like
so each young woman is singing parts of
the equation
and then i have a string quartet that
i'm sampling and running through my
software and this was presented at ucla
and eventually what happens is you have
more and more and more nodes
and the women are wearing black and so
we're projecting on them and i've taken
the equation and then run it through a
logarithmic series of
growth patterns so you can easily see
its relationship to the exponential
growth of the internet so you're hearing
all these young women's voices sort of
cascading around the room
and then sampling the string quartet
through various software that i use
so this is just kind of one project but
this is called quantopia which simply
stands for quantified utopia
now each of the projects i'm presenting
to you you're getting like a three to
five minute version but generally they
take months of research you have to work
with people who commission it you have
to work with it's not every day you can
be a composer and walk in and talk to
the greek government and get the
acropolis i'm just i'm just saying
um so each of these takes a tremendous
amount of research and work
and it then becomes a concert or an
installation or a series of
conversations with data scientists or
other artists
the reason i want to show you guys these
are all totally different projects
is that there has to be a conversation
across silos
and what the problem with early 21st
century is many of us are in our own
side
as a matter of fact if you're a facebook
group or this or that mathematically
speaking you're just kind of in what
there's a theoretician named eli parser
we call the filter bubble you just keep
getting the same thing because you're in
your silo
i want to break down those silos and i'd
like to communicate across mediums and
across disciplines so that's what this
residency is about and i'll be kind of
working with the yale quantum institute
over the next several months and working
with scientists and other people from
your community to figure out a
compelling way to kind of compose and
generate art based on this idea of
breaking down those silos
one of the inspirations for the
residency is a conversation between
these two gentlemen uh on the right you
have rabindranath
who's a bengali
hindu poet
and on the left was einstein so these
guys met backstage at the nobel prize
awards
and stayed in touch uh they einstein
they had the coolest haircuts in the
room
and what ended up happening is they just
got into a series of debates and
discussions and einstein
said to the graduate draft tagore
famously when i'm working on an equation
and i can't finish the equation i go
play violin and people tend to forget
einstein was quite a talented violinist
and so he actually once some of his
favorite compositions are stuff like box
mass and b minor
or box goldberg variations which are
quite mathematical
and so
the um rabbit job tagore said you know
the problem with your western music is
you guys didn't have zero and your
music's too simple and you guys are all
playing minor chord or major chord
and so if you listen to indian music you
can easily hear this rich complexity of
tonality because they incorporated
mathematics into the music at a much
earlier phase in their culture the west
uh still based on the greek model again
pythagoras heraclitus
and you can easily hear that whole tone
um whenever you hear hip hop techno rock
jazz
any of our current music it's still
based on mainly those greek tuning
systems minor chord major chord if
anyone wants to get more technical it's
like lydian phrygian aeolian those are
all ancient greek tribes that just
played a specific style of music and
again if anybody i don't want to lose
half the audience by getting more
technical with music
but
long story short these guys began a
correspondence and their correspondence
was about physics and poetry and it
ended up becoming a book called on the
nature of reality uh it's a great book
where you have one of the world's
leading poets talking to one of the
world's leading physicists and the
conversation between that creative ebb
and flow
is what inspires me for this residency
um i'm a big fan of this idea of people
reaching across different cultural
boundaries and across different silos
and how the 21st century is moving is
that everyone is being put in a date to
data bubble
um based on your algorithmic preferences
and the coercion and surveillance of all
these different social media platforms
so
uh it's time to be human again maybe and
just be in a room with people and i
guess still pandemic and by the way i'm
fully vaccinated
um but i'm a big fan of thinking about
how do we break down these kinds of
issues
and use them as
building blocks for conversation across
the mediums
so um given our time frame it's 5 42. i
know um
that time is tight so i'm going to just
kind of go to this one quote that i
really enjoy using from einstein where
he says imagination is more important
than knowledge knowledge is limited
imagination encircles the world
so to me at least the imagination is the
ultimate renewable resource
we have to think about resilience we
have to think about sustainability and
we have to think about the climate
crisis as basically having to
incentivize us to rethink our
relationship to the patterns that we've
disrupted in the world around us
and that's where quantum physics and
above all thinking about quantum
computing will hopefully allow us to
have a better and more robust and for
one could argue a more powerful
conversation with how to restore some of
the patterns that we've disrupted
um now if we unpack this phrase from the
viewpoint of the arts and thinking about
algorithmic processes and mathematics
and quantum mechanics
the idea of being able to imagine
something that you're unfamiliar with
implies that you have to explore nuance
and you have to be able to kind of if
there's a word that you haven't used and
you've never heard of will you have that
vocabulary if there's an equation or an
approach to something that you've never
engaged will you be able to think about
it and one could argue philosophically
that you might not have the cognitive
processes or structures because you've
never
heard that before or you've never
thought of that before
so the idea for the residency is to kind
of be a provocation and to kind of apply
the logic of the dj which is about
remixing sampling collage
the mash-up
to this notion of how science and the
arts can kind of have a better and more
robust conversation
and to me at least that's a beginning
we're going to see the evolution of that
over the next year and eventually i just
want to show you when i got back from
antarctica um i just want to show you
really quick so i went from this which
is one of the most remote places on
earth um and seeing this massive it
looked like a nuclear bomb had gone off
and the whole continent
it's melting i mean let's just be clear
here
you can easily see that ice is
collapsing the human scale of this is so
mind-boggling and so once you think
about the idea of scalability of
experience
patterns are what allow us to navigate
these kind of issues so when i got back
we had a concert um
you know kind of where me and a group of
other artists
um did a series of uh
uh of music pieces um and each of us did
a different style i've worked with the
hip-hop group the roots which i'm not
sure if you guys are familiar with and
they're also another group called the
flaming lips and each of us did a
different approach so i did one style
they did one style
and i just want to show you the concert
um it's a lot of photos here i always
forget which
but essentially the concert was
uh one of the largest it was for earth
day and what we did was try as much as
possible to kind of engage
the notion of how people would think
about earth day and disruption and
giving people better tools for critical
thinking
to me at least that's one of the most
powerful things we can have
and it really gives us a sensibility
that
the imagination like i was saying
earlier is the ultimate renewable
resource how do we get people to rethink
the process of reimagining what is
possible
um
for one reason or other i can't seem to
find a concert photo but yeah it was a
big concert it was fun i don't know if
you guys know the flaming lips or the
roots
and there everyone it was a popular show
um so
let's see one other thing uh
let's see
trying to make sure to give you guys
some context this is what i do normally
like
kids are rocking out there's that's
about ten thousand people in front of
the stage
i'm using if all these girls are
throwing their bra on the stage um very
on pc you know to say that but it's real
i mean so this is the view from the dj
booth
so i normally you know playing beats and
people are like you know rocking and
stuff like that so this is not what i'm
going to be doing with yale
although maybe we can make some quantum
hip-hop we'll figure
um but the fun part about this is that
it is a social process and to be able to
have fun and also be able to get the
conversation moving outside of the silos
and being able to break those silos down
that's what's going to be the next
several months of what's going on um so
yeah so the concert that we did with for
earth day was something like that but um
all the music that i had made was
generated by the recordings i made in
antarctica um
and
you know amusingly and strangely enough
when you start to think about
project the research that goes into the
project is what makes part of it so
intriguing to me um so i'll be coming up
here
um kind of over the next several months
and just kind of uh having a series of
engagements with
um
uh with scientists with creatives and
above all with people i'm just trying to
figure where is that there's so many
freaking photos
um
there's various videos i can show you
guys there's various oh yeah here we go
so for this one we had about a million
plus people and that's me dj
we filled the entire uh this is at the
dc mall it's in a massive space
so all the music i was playing was
generated in antarctica and i took the
sound of ice i took the sound of the
temperature differentials and then made
electronic music out of it and then the
flaming lips came out and they did their
part of the concert where
they they're like an art rock band i'm
more hip-hop it's again the idea was to
build bridge between styles and then the
roots came out and they're more straight
up normal hip-hop
but i usually do large-scale music
festivals
and um so the audience was into it
because the whole concert was based on
the sounds of nature that had been
cut up spliced and diced into
um
electronic music so if you could party
to the sound of climate change and
anthropocene error
you know um so the good news out of that
is that the audience was able to relate
to the fact that you could actually make
an acoustic portrait of climate change
and that helped raise awareness and we
also had a political engagement with
raising more awareness about climate
change and climate justice
to me that's a really critical issue of
our time um and it's going to be
you know this if i would be surprised if
our species makes it out of this century
personally i know that sounds a little
cynical but
yeah it's pretty bleak um
so
there's plenty of other stuff i could
chat about um i do want to leave time
it's uh 5 50. well could you yeah
give us a little sound since you're keep
showing us pictures of you it sounds are
you going to give us a little
sure i mean i i was going to play a
mashup just to give you a sense of how i
was scratching and also there's plenty
of video of me doing stuff on the
internet anyway um by the way i do want
to i thank you for bringing up and i
will play one thing in one moment but i
do want to emphasize yeah i mean this is
like you know just going some it's not
every day you have a dj from new york go
to the middle of antarctica um
i thought you were going to say that
the middle you guys have quite a few
dj's coming through here i'm pretty sure
um
but the idea here is
think about this as a pattern that's in
disruption you're seeing the collapse of
an entire glacial shelf as a matter of
fact a lot of scientists are saying that
essentially
this entire area is now collapsing into
the ocean
uh when i was there it took about eight
hours to walk from that water all the
way up to the side of this mountain
and i was very hot about it because
you're moving and you by the time i got
to the top of the mountain i've been
wearing all this
gear and i was like oh my god it's
frying
so um
each of these projects requires a
tremendous amount of editing recording
documentation
um but when i got back from going to
this and then had the concert for earth
day
you the audience doesn't see all that
they want like a party or something
that's
you know kind of
immersive and fun
so for me at least this idea of the
research is where i derive personal
satisfaction
um let me play you guys
i mean i have lots of albums out too but
at the antarctica project is
particularly resonant with yale right
now because i think that a lot of it's
going to be about these conversations
with scientists
and um by the way antarctica is the only
place on earth with no government so i
made the entire project open source and
the idea is that you can take the
climate data
and make your own remixes all of this is
available on my website if you go to
djspooky.com and i'll just show you
really quickly
um
the idea was as much as possible to
reference um
let's see
yeah okay so i what i did was take those
temperature differentials this is
temperature over several years this
you're just seeing a small sliver of it
and then take the temperature
differentials assigned to music tone uh
patterns then use those patterns to
generate what you call an algorithmic
musical transcription of weather over a
long period of time
and then use that to generate
music based on these different
algorithmic transcriptions
um again i
i can get more technical if you ever
wants but
basically it's patterns that you can put
into different tempos so house music
techno dubstep hip-hop they're all
patterns so
once you have the basic pattern of the
weather and the temperature
differentials i was able to take that
and make an open source album um the
album is on my website if you just go to
djspoopy.com antarctica
all of the data is there and it was done
with dartmouth's cold regions research
labs
um
each of these projects i could do an
entire talk on just for that product but
i do want to show you some of we're
lifting the hood of the car a little bit
so this is just a little backdrop
um
each of these projects could be full of
but i do wanted to show you really
quickly um the inspiration for that
project was this gentleman johannes
kepler and basically he was on his way
home um in the middle of a snowstorm
and he uh basically
realized a piece of ice had landed on
his sleeve and he wrote the first
equations defining the geometry of ice
um and basically um
you know it's pretty wild this is in the
year 1611. and he's on his way home in
the middle of a snow storm and this geo
like a piece of ice lands on his sleeve
and he realizes how geometric it is
and basically ends up thinking about the
geometry of ice
as um the foundations for this book the
six sides of a snowflake so it's the
first time you have a mathematical
interpretation of the geometry of ice
and you realize you can see the geometry
of ice pretty clearly pretty easily
and what you're seeing is permutations
of the changing same this is literally
the same if you took the same equation
you would be able to generate uh
different things so i was like oh let's
take the equation so what i did was run
it through different patterns
and i took
capillaries material used it to generate
more and more fractal uh kind of
relationships
and you realize after enough computation
you can have synthetic ice and so
basically each of these projects there's
the science component and then there's
the fun component so i need to
i as an artist i was trying to sort of
balance the two
um because you if if you make it too
much then you lose some of the audience
and if you make it too little then you
some of the audience so the good idea is
to be able to
balance
so for example like i was showing you
earlier um
eventually for example this is one of
the installation pieces we had at the
metropolitan museum of art and i took
the geometry of the ice i worked with a
group of architects
and we developed a series of sculptures
that we projected on that was like the
art version and then
that other one were like a million plus
people for earth day that was the
the party version um
so there's plenty of other stuff i could
show you guys but i just want to wrap up
because time it's 5 55.
this is a very i think this
inspirational piece from richard dawkins
where he says science is the poetry of
reality
i began my discussion by showing you
guys the conversation between einstein
and reverend
and i'll end with dawkins uh where this
simple phrase is i think an elegant
distillation of some of the ideas that
are going to be inspiring the residency
over the next several months
and so the idea is to work with you all
work with the institute and see what we
can do from the conversation and again
to go back to the ancient greeks
they would call this a dialectical
process you have thesis antithesis and
synthesis
um so
the gentleman asked for some music
i can play you
there's different versions of everything
uh because that's what the idea of dj
culture it's remix and mashup so i just
want to play one that i find amusing
but it's not definitive of my style
a lot of people
like if you hear the roots you hear
their style or if you hear radiohead
you hear their style for dj culture
anything goes i can take any style and
flip it around so i'll play you because
i grew up in the ancient 1990s when you
guys
weren't born this is a kind of a fun one
i'll just play you a quick clip
[Music]
so that's not what you guys are getting
the art mix that's the party mix so just
um just so we're just to clarify there
um that would work for
like you know um concerts and parties
like this you know so
you guys are getting a different mix
just so
you guys are getting the academics
[Laughter]
exactly yeah so that one you need a big
sound system and a lot of bass so
we're trying to work with the shotgun
center to try to organize uh some fun
events
this is the fun mix so you know i'm
giving you guys the science and stuff
like that but yeah so just so you're
aware i like i said i i inhabit
different ecosystems so this is
that is uh probably you gotta have
lasers and fog you know like if maybe
you guys would come in the room i have
like lasers going or something
[Laughter]
physics is lasers there you go
um all right so thank you guys so much
for your time um and just it's uh
florian how do you want to should we if
you have any questions feel free to ask
them i'll want to hear the chats make
sure that we have
the question from the audience here
[Applause]
i was wondering like when you collect
let's say like weather patterns right
it's got like this interesting pattern
and then you transform into the acoustic
domain do you have any idea what's gonna
sound or is that always a surprise
now um you know there's a couple
approaches
um i'm i've worked with the
mathematician and i'll just show you
really quickly
um
stephen wolfram who's uh probably you
know a pretty legendary
uh mathematician i'll just show you
tones
so this is a project where you can you
can basically compute any style
and hip hop techno dubstep they're
usually a 4-4 tempo for example which is
relatively trivial to compute
then you have minor chord usually most
hip-hop and techno or minor chords etc
so you were able to actually click on
these and start using it to generate
midi and export the midi and then pull
that into an editing what they call
digital audio workstation daw
so when i'm working on a project i
normally don't have the end result in
mind um the process of making the
material
er
you know it depends on the the situation
like if i'm going
for
you guys are more of like um
i you know i don't view today as a party
mix so i would probably not be
uh
but i have other i have that's what i
was mentioning earlier i have many
styles um i'm using this as an example
because he was able to compute almost
every aspect of again using an
algorithmic approach to all of the major
formats of music
but for me at least i'm very interested
in thinking about existing in multiple
ecosystems so
hip-hop might not work for certain
things and then house music might work
for other things and classical music
might work for other things
um and
above all the notion of fidelity to the
beta is not my foundation a lot of
people would say you should only
there are certain other composers um
like ryoji ikeda and you may probably
yeah i have a feeling he's not well done
here he's a japanese composer is
interesting
he'll do visual installations based on
the granular synthesis and he's very
specific about that he projects at the
large scale like small dots and stuff
he's very japanese german minimalism
um that's again like not like a party or
he has very
i'm using him as an example there's
other
artists doing sound art
usually they avoid beats
so you'll go to a gallery and they'll be
like some noise or some sort of glitchy
or skipping cd sound or something but
they never have beats and so i on the
other hand i go more for
you know kind of
incorporating beats with the science
uh but
again i'm not never sure quite if it's
going to be an exact match but it should
be a good beginning point
um yes so you're wondering so you were
saying that
with quantum computing and things that
we
yeah it's
comes a lot of opportunity and i was
wondering because
also coming in with that is another
responsibility
um what you choose to make the quantum
algorithms for example i mean a little
bit better in the future
and it seems that
this
you know this is a very nice opportunity
to mix kind of art and philosophy
and science together so
are you thinking in your project that
you're going to be able to incorporate
that sense of responsibility and those
kind of
ethical questions about what we work on
at all
yeah i mean i'm fascinated with
entanglement for example and i'm going
to use the idea of quantum entanglement
as kind of a foundation for probably
what's part of the residency to look at
einstein call it spooky action at a
distance for example
so when you're thinking about the ethics
of being a composer talking with
scientists or a composer engaging with
you know kind of
things outside of their normal domain
you have to imagine that
it's the beginning of a conversation
and how that conversation goes is the
dialectic um
i i'm this is just beginning so over the
next uh i think is it 12 or 15 months
uh
12 months
for me that's millennia normally i do a
project in like a month maybe um so i
will be coming up to you and also we're
going to host a series of events in new
york as well
uh which you guys are all welcome to
join
we will have uh you know i'll have a
more of a firm date for some of the new
york events but the idea is the
dialectic um
and i'm very intrigued with how the
dialectical process is at the heart both
of science and replicatability um if you
go back to again the ancient greeks
doing
you know experiments and trying to
figure out things
i'm inspired by that because it was like
they had they were just trying to figure
it out and it was kind of like
you know if you're archimedes you're
like i can move the entire world if i
put a lever in the right place and okay
how do you calculate that and he
calculates the entire circumference of
the world
you know there's all sorts of intriguing
possibilities but the ethics of science
versus the arts is very
it's a very
ambiguous place right now um one could
argue that the imagination can be
weaponized too which some people
like for example if you're talking about
entanglement
um
they've already got some satellites in
orbit using quantum entanglement uh the
chinese launched the satellite a little
while ago uh america has launched some
military satellites
they're supposed to be unbreakable
encryption because the entanglement and
all sorts of other processes that go
into that
um you know if
military applications of quantum physics
is definitely a serious issue
uh but one also has to remember
if the americans aren't doing it the
israelis are doing it's not the israelis
and the chinese and it's not the chinese
it's the russians and everybody is
trying to figure this stuff out
and usually it's for some military stuff
personally so as an artist waltzing
through the room you know i i don't have
a machine gun or extra lasers to fire at
anybody
but um it's
the beginning of a conversation to me
about how the arts can help make a
better and non-military approach to
things um a lot of this stuff is being
weaponized immediately like um
military funding for quantum researchers
it's pretty serious um i'm not familiar
with all the numbers but i know it's a
very significant amount of money being
put by the government all major
governments are their military
for like our artificial intelligence
quantum compute and so on
yeah so
we have a question in the chat here um
they say and subject experience is very
cool and i appreciate your focus on
climate change
they advice to work with the yellow
school of environment this year uh and
then also they have a question have you
connected human or human sounds in
antarctica integrate these into your
music
um i'll answer part two first and go to
the first part uh you know i wasn't
interested in human sounds in antarctica
i was interested in the sounds more of
the of nature's processes
because everything has a rhythm even the
absence of a rhythm is kind of a rhythm
so the wind water
uh
even neutrinos we took i tried an
experiment with the
that this project called ice cube
in antarctica that's a neutrino um
measurement center where they're looking
at the impact of neutrinos through the
ice
uh that was interesting
um
human sounds there's there's a lot of
other artists doing that so
i
you know i could there's if you just
google like sound art there's zillions
of people doing stuff
um
in fact there's one who actually this
work i do like marcus buller at mit he's
been doing stuff with the sound of dna
and he's been doing um his most infamous
piece was he took the dna of the covid
virus and made a series of electronic
music pieces out of
the covet
uh
you know which
it it sounds like experimental
electronic music like no beats or
anything
um so the other thing is yeah i would
love to work with yale's environmental
department in fact hopefully we'll reach
out to them um over the next couple of
months
any other question
if not let's uh thank formula again
um i do want to just mention everybody
everything i'm talking about i'm a big
fan of what you call open source culture
so much of the work that i'm doing
is open source and on my website um
there's articles there's downloadable
material uh there's articles and books
uh my books are with mit
uh lately i've been really interested in
this idea of curating um
i just curated a big exhibition about
afrofuturism which is another art
movement that's pretty cool
uh and yeah i'm a big fan of the of the
dialect process so thank you guys so
much for coming out and i hope um to see
you guys over the next couple months